but many people who visit your office
know about you some what it does no it
did basically takes about 10 minutes to
even explain what what the gist of it is
but most people know that I've got seven
or eight computers working all the time
in my office on something what do they
think about that I think they think it's
a bit nutty and I care so a lot of
people think that - what do you I think
it's probably worth it when time will
tell
to most physicists I guess lambda
probably means the length of a wave it
means how long is the distance between
one peak of a wave and the next one very
easy to understand water waves traveling
along a pond but too many engineers and
particularly people who do dynamics
lambda means an eigenvalue it's a
special value a special number that you
get out of a matrix that tells you
something very important about the
nature of that matrix
the word is eigenvalue some people would
call them proper values or
characteristic values it's a mixture of
a German word and an English word
obviously eigenvalue is and I'm not sure
what the exact literal translation is
but it means a special number that
characterizes the matrix and if you have
a matrix that is ten by tens as ten rows
in it and ten columns of numbers in it
it will have ten ikon values
people often ask well what physical
significance can there be two
eigenvalues and I can show you two very
simple instances of that one has to do
with vibration and if I cantilever this
ruler off the side of the bench and
excited with some initial condition then
you see that the ruler goes into an
oscillation and the oscillation
gradually dies away and we see two
different parts to the vibration of this
ruler one is the oscillating part which
has a certain frequency and I'm going to
guess that that's about four times per
second about four Hertz but also you see
the decay part that the oscillations are
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
as we go through time and the lambda has
both of those parts built into it so
there's one good example this is a very
simple structure in engineering we have
to analyze very complex structures that
have excitation not just some giant
person flicking the end of the structure
but they have sinusoidal excitation from
motors turning and from loads moving
backwards and forwards that if they hit
an eigenvalue really will shake that
structure to bits and a second physical
application for eigenvalues is also
demonstrably with a ruler and it's the
buckling load of a ruler if you stand a
ruler up vertically you can put a
certain amount of weight on the top of
it and it will stay perfectly steady
and as you increase the amount of weight
and I'm doing this with my hand it will
remain steady until you come to a
certain point and just happened here
where the load is just too much for the
ruler to bear and that particular load
is called a critical load or a buckling
load for the ruler and you find that out
by doing a calculation which is an
eigenvalue problem I know of one other
application that probably everybody in
England uses Zygon values every single
day and that is the Google search engine
it formulates its search problem as a
giant eigenvalue problem with a matrix
that probably guessing has millions of
rows and millions of columns
sparsely-populated not not a number in
every single place and it calculates the
eigenvalues of this huge matrix and uses
that to determine which entries should
show you first the problem of finding
out i ghen values is quite specialized
to different sorts of systems and my
particular interests are in so-called
second order systems so problems where
you don't just have one matrix you have
three matrices this is the quadratic I
can value problem for three matrices K
and D and M K represents the stiffness
of a structure D represents the damping
M represents the mass of that structure
and the key word is iso spectral the
spectrum is the set of eigenvalues for a
system and i am making an iso spectral
transformation i already know what the
equation is that describes these flows
i'm looking to find the solution to the
equation and i'm using the computers
behind you to do that and and i have
been using those for several years and
often these running 24 hours a day seven
days a week the black one is running all
the time some of the other ones i switch
off when i'm not able to give it much
time so typically i in a working week I
can only give this ten minutes in the
morning and that has to do just to keep
it going and in those cases I have two
of them running alongside the black one
but if it's the middle of vacation I
have four
and I updated twice a day last summer I
figured out a way that made it quite a
bit quicker and I thought that that
would probably get me there inside a
year and in fact that's still not there
this coming so we're probably I find out
a way to make it even quicker